up-up DC video DC video hold on hold on
got a pander necessary pandering okay
okay thank god oh good you really want
to have
we're gonna watch today from new rock
stars batman first look breakdown camera
test soon reveal easter eggs from new
rock stars with my favorite channels i'm
greg alba
this is juliet juliet sorrow is here
filmmaker model follow her on Instagram
and twitch she's great she's awesome
met her through mister Campea
self-proclaimed great and awesome I just
showed her she actually didn't catched
the first look at Robert Pattinson as
Batman so I just showed her a footage
she was drooling all over him drooling
it was obnoxious comedy like but can we
still film this reaction this channel I
have not they are fantastic best theory
and breakdown Easter Egg channel I've
ever seen hands down get ready to get
some information in the Batsuit in cow
in Mattoon with directing test footage
with some interesting lighting choices
interesting music I know it's less than
a minute it's just a camera test but
we're already getting much fun of
information from daredevil that name
here so let's shake it my dear BB Stars
tweet down
it's World War II in case any my Batman
predictions that'll be to write it
somehow ruined the movie boys let's do I
had been loving how Warner's DC pumps
have gotten bud started early with
interesting camera test duties the looks
yes smart they did with Joker and birds
a plate in this case it's just a simple
look at Pattinson as the Batman bathed
in red light and ominous Imperial March
style music bulky Brucie's that Ben
Affleck and Christian Bale were now sure
this camera test was probably done early
in pre-production but there have been
some reports of Pattinson has had a bit
of trouble beefing up but that's
probably okay though since other reports
that suggested that Reeves story we'll
follow a younger Bruce Wayne not
necessarily Batman year one but maybe
like the second year as a ninja lantee
and detective so that's being early on
of Bruce's like this could be his first
prototype she's gonna be working out a
lot in this movie yeah it doesn't appear
to have pronounced ears it's actually
pretty similar to the original 1939
Batman emblem what we get a car bounce
will look like when you remove at the
red light aid so yeah now you could say
this implement peers to be removable
battery looks like a split shaft of a
gun what they're this could be the gun
of Joe Chill the one he used to murder
Bruce's parents too now Batman is using
it as a chess piece as a reminder to not
kill now many are comparing the music
and the music continues the low piano
notes give away two horns evoke in Danny
Elfman's Batman theme
man themed about me in the animated
series this original score and he said
it I already finished writing the main
theme of the movie this may be what
we're hearing here the camera moves up
to the face and the cowl and if you
brighten and adjust the contrast that
looks like stitching on the cowl as if
it's made of leather above the eye holes
are pronounced eyebrows making this cow
more of a theatrical mask and casting
like covers over the eyes the overall
look to the look for me sure good brings
that the ridge we work for them really
yeah everyday goods with standard you
don't respect the product place it
gently and respected in all the product
placement better living is rich if
you're watching check out Julia's
Instagram I'm actually loving it that's
if they're like we watched you rock star
yeah they're him they're happening but
what the MTV generation are in kid
wallet that's designed to streamline
what you carry every day it has the
video a better way to carry your cash
and cards there's a lifetime no more
Batman we're gonna spend the rest of the
video we're talking about the bags
today with free worldwide shipping and
returns by going to Ridge comm slash new
rock stars that's rich Khan / new rock
stars and used to code new rock stars
find the link in the video's description
ok sitting the Batman in Arkham could
explain why so many villains have been
cast
zowie crime innocence plane Selina Kyle
will be playing Edward Nash - the
Riddler Colin Farrell is slain Oswald
Cobblepot penguin John Turturro is crime
boss carmine Falcone Peter Sarsgaard is
playing a new character listed as Gil
Coulson Gotham's District Attorney some
rumors are saying that it could be a
Harvey Dent toothpaste figure Matt
Reese's this final script as a war story
one theory that we have speculated is
that all these members of the rogues
gallery could be imprisoned within
Arkham Batman now at the interview each
of them for clues on a new mystery
figure he's trying to hunt down similar
to Newtown to the lamps others have
suggested an annotation of hush a story
that involves several Batman villains
really a story that gives the Riddler a
very big role but we know that there
will be lots of action Pattinson has
been training in Brazilian Jujitsu with
instructor Regan Machado who worked on
John wick Pandolfo voice inspired by
Willem Dafoe's voice when they
co-starred in a lighthouse together I am
[Laughter]
the Batman they have a similar focus at
Crystal and use for the Dark Knight a
story that it mixes crime with political
corruption a story about the very soul
of Gotham City folks you really should
join new rockstars official discord to
participate okay let me build a version
of this conversation my super dark
theory but where I really want this
movie to go okay daredevil Batman really
moves the blood around the body to doing
this inner circle become a patron today
at patreon.com slash new rock stars
comment down below with your plot theory
for the Batman follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at da boss all the new rock
stars and subscribe to new rock stars
here and this is what it looks like
eatin fondue of all right let's talk
about some of their theories the
Batarang stuff people have speculated
that might be a gun from the killer who
killed his parents that's a stretch but
even so there's two of them what's the
other gun I mean fair point
yeah I personally think that's a stretch
I think it's a cool theory I would
actually like it if they just let it be
a theory and didn't even acknowledge
what it was yeah because they had the
one theory so he made it out of the guns
and then you can take it off it's a
tractable Batarang that he could use and
it flies back it goes right back I like
it if you pull it off and they were just
two guns yeah I mean that would be
something new yeah yeah people don't
want Batman using guns but I like the
symbolism behind it of a reminder not to
kill and it does seem like a Batman
thing to do to bear the guilt right here
on his heart it's super bad like yeah I
agree with you it's a little how do you
have gotten the guns well I don't think
as a child parents you would have to do
a lot of research to find the evidence
Locker forever those guns are yeah it's
a nice theory Bruce Wayne is capable
probably of doing it they were talking
about how he's like exceptionally lean
in this one like their reports are
saying that he's having trouble bulking
up and then the other reports were
saying that's burly Batman stages so
this is why the suit looks this way and
maybe that's why Batman's a little bit
more lean this time around is this movie
gonna be like Batman every 10 minutes
like bulking up in LA Fitness or
something like taking a lot of protein
shakes now I want to see them really
focus on Batman trying to get his body
to the shape he wants it to be a take
Batman's weight training class today
bunch of retired mothers Batman's
cycling class they were saying there
with all the other villains at one
theory is that there at Arkham Asylum
and that he's interviewing them cuz
there's a new villain in town so he's
trying to get the lowdown on them I kind
of feel like that contradicts though the
concept that this is supposed to be
early Batman right because of its early
Batman why does he have so much of his
great ro gallery villains locked away in
Arkham Asylum I feel like we'll be
missing out on so much goodies if that's
the case
you know I mean obviously earlier than
whatever age Ben Affleck was that I know
this is not the same Batman at all I
just think that's a little bit
contradictory to the argument to the
point of the plot set up the pitch of it
all his jaw line is great is his jaw
line is fantastic
have you seen the lighthouse no oh man
have you heard Willem Dafoe talk in that
movie no I heard oh my god I gotta show
you just a snippet of Willem Dafoe
[Music]
that's our new Batman right there our
past is now saying his voice is gonna be
inspired by Willem Dafoe hi I'm the
Batman I am the Dark Knight here are our
commotions that would be the best bad I
hope that scene from the win the Red
Room that they have this test footage
he's just brooding alright guys well
what are your theories for Batman the
new Batman movie off the 1 minute test
footage some movie news reports let's
speculate for the next year subscribe to
new rock stars if you haven't done so
subscribe to the real rejects click the
notification bell follow Juliet sirot
steer how do people pronounce her name
wrong sure oh sorry through what a bunch
of idiots follow Juliet super rocky on
Instagram and twitch and a citizen of
the nation
michail Lyndon McHale it's only fitting
got you a poem buddy here we go one day
I will sail to give an in person hail to
the handsome man named McHale
he speaks of his homeland Sweden as if
it's part of the glorious land the
Garden of Eden send him a message he's
quick to respond huge fan of James Bond
polyamorous amongst the blondes ladies
look out shows them his double-oh-seven
and he goes to town during seven minutes
in heaven loves unique talkies skilled
in the sport of hockey pass him a ball
and soccer and he'll make love wearing a
choker turn off the lights in the
dungeon make sure to address him as mr.
Lindon I disappointed him because I had
a malfunction and region Jena tation